is
okay so if if he lifts up
into me he can't lift the elbow lift the
elbow
well if i have a good cook you i don't i
don't even need the grip though
if if i have good cookie i don't even
need the fingers
he can't do it he can't do it though
can't do it
if i make a pinching move that i
come to a point here with his elbow and
his fingers
it doesn't affect the gambie roll go
that's not me
if i have an extreme angle on his wrist
uh it does nothing for the gambiro
[Music]
if i turn his elbow all the way as they
exaggerate it
actually helps the gambi roll closer
if i turn it back in some weird variant
of eko which is
okay same thing happens
in nikkio katakatame
same thing he'll do the game b roll
again only
nothing happens
same thing happens on kill same thing he
goes nothing happens
come on this side of me
let's get you in the cars
same thing happens in the kimura if you
don't guard against the roll
he's out
same thing happens
in the omaha if you don't guard against
the role
hence why in the camera you guard
against the wall with your leg try to
roll
you can't you're going to get
same on the club